good day Internet another day another
drone so I realized looking for my
videos the horizon level has been off so
i justed the gimbal so you guys might
not have been able to tell because I
adjusted it manually in Final Cut Pro
but now you can adjust it on the drone
which I did and I'm going to put this
thing in sport mode today this is gonna
be my first time in sport mode says
it'll go up to 45 miles an hour so you
guys are gonna witness it here baby
that wasn't sport mode just wanted to
test and make sure everything look good
and this is sport mode
Wow Wow Wow
this thing is so fast I cannot wait to
get the Phantom 4 Pro I can't with you
my mammoth my god I love technology
before we left today Jenna and ed and
Allison we all went on a hike and masses
hey can I borrow your GoPro cuz I want a
suction cup it to my car I don't know
how many times I could say it I'm gonna
buy you a new one tomorrow I suction
it's so hard on the car and I thought I
had it locked on really really well I
even tested it but as soon as we got off
the side street and onto the main road
on top all that jb is kind of the hero
here I went into the middle of traffic
to go get it
he likes stop the car I was like Matt
just be really careful cuz I don't think
this is gonna actually stick we come
back and this is what I'm presented by
Madi we're changing your name that looks
great
we gotta change the dog name now let's
review the footage
it's like wedged in there like the whole
ball of like you know like the GoPro
right so then I part is because this is
a hero 5 it doesn't usually you don't
need to have a case on it because it is
waterproof but it's not damage proof I
mean oh wow I'm sure it's the works this
is the one scratch so you can't see a
scratch
this is not scratched the whole top of
this whole thing is gone it's missing do
you see that
oh that's the Steadicam this table there
it goes yeah come off it's just it's
trying to stabilize
oh yeah right in a ball go through that
off when you're ready measure here cuz
oh it's a linear mode - oh it's rolling
on I grab it
that's how using my fire just is gonna
kill me hi how are you hello we're here
to see Santa and we're gonna get in line
and then we're gonna see Santa are you
recording we're going into the Big Bear
toy store
she's John trying to this is what I got
this hat is Maddie I can't wait to show
ed because I think he's gonna make it
fun
it looks like naughty looks like naughty
on my head Oh looks like Maddie and a
bear yeah whoa bear that's pretty good
what's it look like oh it's on your head
do you think they have hot chocolate
I smell mint and Happiness oh god I
think in this JB Jeff Burke takes Jeff
Jeff Jeff
oh hi do I need them Jeff hi oh no Jeff
hello jack hey I'll take one
take me and their Sansa it's it's cold I
finished my chocolate already we're in
high win everybody spot warm yeah I'd
still need to slam it
we're packing up we are heading home
today from Big Bear I hate packing I
feel like my life is just always packing
and going somewhere Jimmy Jack for a
Jeff this is Jeff bark meet Jeff where
we going
I feel like I'm gonna get one last drone
shot like I can't leave this place and
not get a good drone shot cuz I
basically have droned all over this
entire area but just one more just one
more
me on the car God so many just creepy
things in themselves there you go Maddie
you've got such a little boys now
made it home didn't unpack basically
just came in took it happened that was
about it so as you saw towards the
middle I guess to this video this is at
that I just bought I was very excited
about it it was super cute another
reminded me of my sweet sweet dog and
then my sweet sweet dog got ahold of it
it's this what's on my head honey you
see something that you just destroyed
well thank you guys so much for watching
hope you guys enjoyed the big bear
videos and now it's back to MacBook and
iPhone videos every single day instead
of drone videos at a cabin I love flying
the drone so much I love flying them
look at you just rested I love this dog
see you guys later bye not much room to
take off or land here so I'm gonna have
to be extra precise so we know how I am
about precision dogs trying to come out
oh there's a lot of people over there
now where did they come from I think one
of the things that I love about flying
drones is